firstly is your ideal situation to
simply be a research professor i know
some professors
don't they treat teaching as an aside
they don't particularly like to do it
i'm curious about your case
well
ideologically
i mean
i see myself as a teacher
even the research in some sense
is to support teaching
even the research is so that i will
remain in shape
and
even more so and that the community will
remain in shape so you know if if i do
research i am able to
teach graduate students how to do
research
and then they are
uh become
uh stronger mathematicians and can teach
mathematics better so so so so so i even
see researchers mostly
supporting
teaching
so
i definitely wouldn't say that i see
everything as research right i mean
research
again teaching is very significant
well that's the theory
in practice
um
you know waking up every morning and
preparing your class and this marathon
of teaching
where you have to prepare your class
you
teach
you feel
terrible about the things you missed
during class
you don't even have time to digest it
and you have to get ready for the next
class already
so uh
you know
it's very hard
i mean people who haven't done that
don't appreciate how it how hard it is
but it's emotionally very very difficult
and uh after a semester of teaching
uh uh
you have no idea how much i i'm i'm
looking forward to the break so it's not
like teaching is
you know i
when i teach i want out
do you find that to be true even if it's
an undergraduate course the reason i ask
this is that i imagine as a professor
the undergraduate material you could
teach with your pinky you don't have to
think much about it because you first of
all you've mastered it second you've
taught it for years and years i do not
teach the same class
for years
like
i think the maximum i've ever repeated
the class
uh was like three years
so it's not
but
but even then uh you always have to
prepare
uh
you always blunder i always blunder
maybe perfect people don't
but you know i always blunder uh
and there and then i have to figure out
ways out
i always
find new things to do new ways to do
things i always um
even when i repeat but essentially but
most of the time i don't repeat
and the material is sometimes hard you
know so um
and even when it's not hard
so you know
on day one of the class
uh you teach of a linear algebra class
you teach the axioms of a vector space
i obviously know these axioms right i
obviously um
when i see a vector space
i know it
when i when when you give me a vector
space i know what to do with it
but that's not the same thing
as getting up in front of a class and
listing the axioms
and
making sure that you haven't forgotten
one small axiom somewhere
or that you phrase them perfectly so
that even people who have never seen
these things before will understand
um
so i mean even day one of a very basic
class
requires preparation
we're going to talk about mathematical
techniques
in fact i believe when we emailed you
said you don't like the emphasis on
theorems and proofs you like
well we can talk about that later
as for
teaching techniques i'm curious what
have you gleaned what have you found to
be productive and perhaps even some
behaviors you find to be unproductive
that you see other people other teachers
making the mistake of doing
i mean there is so much
uh
you know starting from
com
you know completely silly things like
make sure that you're heard
right if the classroom is large and you
speak without a microphone
uh people in the back are not going to
hear you and then they're not going to
follow
make sure that you can be seen
so if you write with a tiny you know if
you write tiny letters with a faded
chalk
uh
people can't read what you write
the class is a failure no matter what
you say
and then there are
higher level things and
basically everything should be motivated
so you know i mentioned the first class
of a linear at the first class uh in a
linear algebra course
okay so you can give by uh you can give
by this class
by saying uh you can start this class by
saying let f be a field
ah
a set
v
is
called
a vector space if
and then you can write property you know
operations and properties and you know
you write item number one to item number
15
where 15 is i don't know some axioms
like alpha times beta times a vector
you know whatever so one of the axioms
of a vector field
okay of a vector sorry a vector space
uh
and then the question arises why
and who cares
right right okay so if you start your
class this way
people aren't going to like it so before
this
there has to be a a little section
i don't know here
where you explain
um
well
for such and such reasons we care about
vector spaces so there has to be
motivation first
okay
and
uh
and that's true
not only in the first class of the first
um
uh
of a linear algebra course it's true
in every class when whenever you say
something there has to be a reason
and the people who um
uh
who are listening to you uh
should know that you've thought about it
should know that you
that you're telling them these things
for a reason okay
and
uh that's often omitted
it's often
too easy to just follow the definitions
and the theorems and never say what
they're good for
and
um
and not only you should say the things
that you should say them up from up
front
likewise when you write a proof
uh
it's often easy to
well to
to so i mean often there is a picture
behind that proof
the proof is telling some story
and you
and you want the picture of that story
in the minds of the students
but but but but it's often too easy to
reduce it to a
list of formulas
or a list of statements so a higher
level thing is to make sure that
everything is motivated
what else what's another higher level
aspect of teaching
that you find is a common mistake among
the teachers that you see
um
i think maybe this is the biggest
not showing the motivation clearly
enough
and
by the way
uh
that's part of the reason why research
is a necessary part of teaching
because
uh
you have to know the motivation
you know you can say
vector spaces are a great thing
unless you've actually worked with them
unless you've actually seen them used
so maybe vector spaces are good and are
easy enough so that you can um
[Music]
you know by third year you understand
why you why you learned about them in
first year
uh but if you want to be able to say
something intelligent about homology you
have to have used it
the only way to use it is in research
so
uh
so that's what i meant by you have to be
in shape being in shape also means
remember what
what can be done with these things